Hey guys, it is Issa Rae.
We are currently
in Inglewood, California,
shooting the fifth episode
of our fourth season.
It's the block party episode,
it's finally here.
I'm so excited
to give you a tour.
Follow me.
Oh, okay, follow me though.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
Trips me out is that
this street
is gonna change so much
by next year.
This is like a rare opportunity
to be able to do this.
Because obviously,
Inglewood is changing so much.
So, we went about choosing
these vendors,
we surveyed the writer's room.
Obviously, I'm from here,
Prentice is from here.
I personally am so excited
about showcasing real
black businesses,
that we frequent.
We're highlighting
specific restaurants,
and stores
that wouldn't be highlighted
in other shows.
Come on. This is fire.
The entire production
and set design team
really planned this,
since we were shooting
the first episode.
Issa Dee really did this.
But she didn't really do this,
our set design team did.
So, shout out to them.
In choosing some of the artists
to represent Issa's block party,
obviously, Issa's from L.A.,
she reps L.A. super hard.
And we wanted to have the finest
of L.A. artists.
CROWD: (CHANTING)
Vince! Vince! Vince!
Give it up for Vince Staples!
Vince Staples is a legend.
He says what he wants to say.
He is such a dope artist
to me.
We've been featuring his music
since the first season.
And such a high-profile artist
for Issa Dee to get.
Hey, DJ, drop that.
♪ We bringing back the Wobble ♪
So "the Wobble" is a staple
in the black community
in general.
So we knew that, in this moment,
to bring Issa
and Molly together,
what better dance
than the Wobble,
to reunite them?
And so that was a really fun
scene to shoot
with 300 to 500 extras.
And I could not be more proud
of the vision
of this block party realized.
It was so much fun.
Okay, you guys,
I hope you enjoyed
the block party tour.
I hope you enjoy this episode.
I actually have to get back
to work.
I'll catch y'all later.
Bye.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪